وينضم الينا من باريس مدير مكتب العربيه
في فرنسا حسين قنيبر اهلا بك معنا الليله
حسين يعني اليوم هو العاشر من ايام هذه
الاحتجاجات بسبب قانون التقاعد الجديد في
فرنسا هلا لخصت لنا هذا اليوم كيف صار منذ
بدء الاحتجاجات والان ما هو الوضع
المحدوده بين الشرطه ومن بقي من
المتظاهرين بعضهم ينتمي الى مجموعات بلاك
بلوك الفوضويه من اقصى اليسار بل من
اليسار المتطرف وبعضهم من المتظاهرين
الناشطين الشريحه الاكبر من المتظاهرين
غادرت ساحه الامه وكان هذا النهار شهد
مواجهات خصوصا في ليل شمالا في نوت غربا
في بوردو في الجنوب الغربي واليون في
الجنوب الشرقي طبعا كانت هناك تبادلات كان
هناك تبادل للاتهامات بين الحكومه من جهه
والنقابات والاحزاب احزاب اليسار تحديدا
من جهه اخرى بعد ان اكدت اليزابيث خلال
اجتماع ان تراسه ماكرون في قصر الاليزيه
يوم امس انها منفتحه على حوار مع النقابات
في الايام المقبله وانها ستستقبل قاده
احزاب المعارضه مطلع شهر المقبل عاده
اليوم لتؤكد ردا على اقتراح النقابات قيام
وساطه بين النقابات والحكومه قالت الوزراء
ان اي شيء لن يغير من واقع ان قانون رفع
سن التقاعد لن يعلق وسينفذ هذا اعاد
الامور الى دائره المراوحه رد
زعيم اقصى اليسار احد ابرز زعماء حركه
فرنسا الابيه بالقول ان على اليزابيث ان
ترحل هي واصلاحها اي هي واصلاح التقاعد
نظام التقاعد وقال المتحدث باسم الحزب
الشيوعي ايضا طالما اننا نتحدث عن مواقف
اليسار
المتحدث الشيوعي قال ان المكسر الاول
والمخرب الاول في فرنسا هو قصر الاليزيه
ردا على اتهامات الاليزيه لجماعات يساريه
باللجوء الى التخريب خلال التظاهرات راويه
حسين انتهى وقتي ولكن سؤال يعني سريع جدا
موقف النقابات من اعمال العنف التي حصلت
اللي هي من اليمين واليسار المتطرف او
البلاك بلاك
طبعا هم يقولون انهم يدينون العنف من اي
جهه اتى لكنهم يرون ان العنف يكون احيانا
في الشارع ردا على عنف تمارسه الشرطه فيما
رد وزير الداخليه في تصريحات مفصله امس
قائلا انه منذ السادس عشر من هذا الشهر
وحتى مساء امس جرح 891 دركيا وشرطيا في
اعمال عنف قام بها انصار اقصى اليسار
وانصار اليسار المتطرف اذا اتهامات
متبادله بين الشرطه من جهه
والنقابات واحزاب اليسار بشان المسؤوليه
عن اعمال العنف راويه شكرا جزيلا لك من
باريس مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين
قنيبر